DAN STONE: How's it
going, everybody?
Thanks for coming.
DANIEL HANDLER: Hello.
DAN STONE: This
is Daniel Handler.
DANIEL HANDLER: Hi.
DAN STONE: Our guest for today.
DANIEL HANDLER: How are you?
Thank you for coming.
DAN STONE: We're
happy to be here.
DANIEL HANDLER: We're
gonna get you all smashed.
DAN STONE: That's the goal.
My name is Dan Stone.
I'm the editor of
Radio Silence Magazine.
It's based up in San Francisco.
Daniel and I have known each
other for quite a while.
I first interviewed him about
Edgar Allan Poe years ago,
when I was still living in
DC, about a reading program.
And then when I moved to
San Francisco years later,
I started bartending at a place
in the city called the Alembic,
and he's a big
cocktail fan, as am I.
So we kind of solidified
our friendship across a bar.
So when we were asked to
come down and do this,
we thought it would be
good to set up a bar
and serve drinks to all of you.
Talk about some stuff.
DANIEL HANDLER: Yeah.
It's fulfilling a long time
fantasy of getting everyone
at Google really drunk
in the afternoon.
DAN STONE: He's been talking
about this for years.
DANIEL HANDLER: I'm assuming
this is everyone, anyway.
I'm assuming there are
no other employees.
I understand it's
just is a small--
DAN STONE: A couple
people missing, maybe.
DANIEL HANDLER:
Intimate company.
DAN STONE: So you guys
probably know who Daniel is.
This magazine, Radio Silence, is
focused on literature and rock
and roll, which are two
of my favorite things,
and also two of the things
that this guy excels in.
So he's a writer.
Of course you know
him as the guy
who wrote all the
Lemony Snicket books.
He also has written several
novels for adults-- "The Basic
Eight," "Watch Your Mouth,"
"Adverbs," "Why We Broke Up,"
and this amazing book
coming out next year that I
don't know if we're
allowed to name.
DANIEL HANDLER: Yeah.
DAN STONE: Can we name
it? "We Are Pirates."
Is it February?
DANIEL HANDLER: It's
called "We Are Pirates."
Yeah.
It's coming out in February.
DAN STONE: It's so good.
I love it.
DANIEL HANDLER: I'll
let him compliment it.
I'll say the title, and
then he can compliment it.
"We Are Pirates."
DAN STONE: It's great.
Great.
It's great.
DANIEL HANDLER: Yeah.
Because if it were the
reverse, it would be awkward.
DAN STONE: Right.
DANIEL HANDLER: If you were
saying what it was called,
and I was saying,
and it's dynamite.
DAN STONE: Right.
Right.
Yeah.
So we have a kind
of strange idea
for how we want to
structure this hour.
We're going to make
drinks, but we also
want to talk about a few
works of art that are not his.
We might talk about
some of yours, too.
DANIEL HANDLER: Yeah.
DAN STONE: Want to
explain the idea?
DANIEL HANDLER: Who
knows what we'll do?
Because we'll get
full of liquor soon.
DAN STONE: Tell them.
I'm going to start
making the first drink.
DANIEL HANDLER: OK.
We thought we would talk
about things that we like
and drinks that go with
it, which is basically
how I talk to just
about anyone I know.
And we're going to
start with the gimlet.
You say you serve
gimlets to everybody.
This is a good
first drink to you?
DAN STONE: Oh, yeah.
I haven't served
them to everybody,
but I think it's a
great afternoon drink,
it's a good brunch drink,
it's a good summer day drink--
it's classic.
DANIEL HANDLER: It's versatile.
DAN STONE: It is.
DANIEL HANDLER: And you're
using this cool device that
looked like a sex toy when
you unpacked it, but is,
in fact, also a citrus squeezer.
DAN STONE: Yeah.
Antique citrus squeezer.
So we've got drinks
coming around.
Pass them down the aisle.
Those are some pre-batch
gimlets we did for you.
And we're going to drink gimlets
and talk about crime fiction.
DANIEL HANDLER: Do you say your
recipe for the gimlet first?
DAN STONE: Oh, yeah.
DANIEL HANDLER: I guess
it's right up there.
Our friend Wendy drew the
drinks and wrote the recipe
underneath.
DAN STONE: Yeah.
Wendy McNaughton, an
artist in San Francisco--
she did these for everyone.
If you want to make these
at home, there you go.
Yeah.
Two ounces of gin.
I mean, there's a lot
of recipes for it.
I make one slightly less sweet.
Half ounce of simple
syrup, and then a couple
dashes of orange bitters.
DANIEL HANDLER: I just always
put sugar in my gimlet,
because I find simple syrup
too much of a pain to make.
DAN STONE: I can see that.
DANIEL HANDLER: Yeah.
I mean, I'm just
at home, lonely.
DAN STONE: Just shake
the hell out of it?
DANIEL HANDLER: Yeah.
DAN STONE: There we go.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
DAN STONE: We can do a
commercial for Beefeater.
DANIEL HANDLER: Yeah.
Beefeater, the gin Daniel
Handler's mother prefers.
DAN STONE: My gin tastes are
pretty much simple London Dry.
I like Bombay Dry a lot.
DANIEL HANDLER: I
guess you and my mother
are alike in that way.
DAN STONE: Yeah.
DANIEL HANDLER: Yeah.
DAN STONE: What are
your gin tastes?
DANIEL HANDLER:
I like a gin that
tastes like you've been
rolling around in a forest.
It reminds me of my
wild and reckless youth
where I used to take girlfriends
to [INAUDIBLE] woods.
DAN STONE: Nice.
Kind of dirty gin, sounds like?
DANIEL HANDLER: Oh, I thought we
were talking about high school
again.
Whatever I could get
away with, basically.
Yeah, I like a
like-- I don't know.
It smells herbal, but not like
some of them smell, potpourri.
There are some gins that smell
like a scented candle store,
and I'm opposed to that.
I'm opposed to it in a
scented candle store, come
to think of it, and I'm
also opposed to it in a gin.
DAN STONE: Right.
OK.
DANIEL HANDLER: You're going
to shake it and then strain it?
DAN STONE: That's right.
Yeah.
We have an extra large ice
scoop for the occasion,
so we might make some mistakes.
DANIEL HANDLER: Never.
But we're making gimlets
as the first round,
which I hope you're
all drinking.
I'm going to be very upset
if I see people taking
a little token sip, because my
ultimate fantasy is that we all
get really liquored up,
we get into a Google bus,
and we go over to
the Bing campus
and we just start some stuff.
I don't know what it is.
DAN STONE: Missing one tool.
DANIEL HANDLER: Yeah.
DAN STONE: I'll wing it.
AUDIENCE: You can walk.
DANIEL HANDLER: We can walk?
We don't need to get there--
but getting there by Google bus
is kind of cooler.
DAN STONE: You're that close?
Because they know what's coming?
DANIEL HANDLER: You're like,
sorry, we were using MapQuest
and now we're lost.
Boom.
That's all you have to say.
Like making simple
syrup, straining
is never anything I
do, because it's just
another thing to wash.
DAN STONE: Right.
DANIEL HANDLER: But you do it.
You're a pro.
DAN STONE: We can
have more if you want.
Those look a little
small in these glasses.
DANIEL HANDLER: Cheers.
DAN STONE: Cheers.
Cheers, everybody.
DANIEL HANDLER: Yeah.
DAN STONE: Is this the
first gimlet for anyone?
A couple.
All right.
DANIEL HANDLER: Well, today.
Yeah.
DAN STONE: Oh, that's
what I meant, yeah.
I meant today.
They have them on
tap in Building 39
It's marked drinking fountain.
DANIEL HANDLER: So
I like a gimlet too,
and gimlets are a-- well,
where should I start?
So there's a Lemony
Snicket series
that is out now, as
opposed to the one
that was out when you
were in grade school.
And this is called "All
the Wrong Questions."
And "A Series of
Unfortunate Events"
was my take on Gothic
literature-- on Wuthering
Heights and other stories
of that ilk, in which
strange and sinister things
which happened a long time ago
are coming to bear on poor,
wretched people wandering
around terrible landscapes.
And after 13 volumes
of that, I began
to get interested in noir,
in which corrupt people are
wandering around
more industrially
sinister landscapes, working on
secrets that probably they'll
never figure out,
and being forced
to behave more immorally.
Which also seemed to me like
the journey of childhood--
that in a typical
noir detective story,
the detective is
hired to do a case,
and then the people are
lying to him about that case.
And then as he discovers
this framework,
then they say,
lay off that case.
It's solved.
We told you it's solved.
And the detective
says, no, I'm going
to find my own solution to it.
And that, to me, feels like
childhood, where everyone's
lying to you about
what's important.
And you gradually figure out,
wait a minute, this whole thing
is corrupt.
And they're like, no no no,
stay in line, stay in line,
stay in line.
And you say, no, I'm going
to find my own moral path
in a world gone
hopelessly wrong,
and live long enough to
invoke it on other people.
As we're all doing.
We're older than
we've ever been.
DAN STONE: Yeah.
DANIEL HANDLER: And
now we're even older.
And "The Long Goodbye,"
by Raymond Chandler,
one of the great American
novels in the world,
was a focus of obsession for
me at various different ages.
I first read it in high
school, and I loved it.
I thought it was so sexy.
I really hoped that I could
live the life of the characters
in "The Long Goodbye."
Not even just the detective,
but kind of everybody,
getting kind of wrecked
and sad all the time.
Turns out even
when you're young,
it's kind of rough on you.
But as I grew older, I
admired it more and more
as a well crafted novel--
that the language in it
is hopelessly
beautiful and lost.
And I also think it's a great
portrait of male friendship.
I think it's a
good book for a man
to give a woman who is
puzzled about his friends.
I'm sure that's never
happened to anybody.
Because it is
basically the story
of a friendship in which
Philip Marlowe, the detective,
is friends with Terry Lennox
based on hardly anything
at first.
DAN STONE: Kind of a
troubled friendship.
DANIEL HANDLER: Yeah.
And it's a troubled
friendship-- and then
keeps sticking up for
him way past all reason,
but in a way that's
quite beautiful.
It's beautiful as a love story.
I've seen some people cast it as
a love story between men, which
I don't think it is, because
the men seem quite heterosexual.
DAN STONE: They do.
DANIEL HANDLER: I say this
as kind of a simpering sissy
myself, that they seem
extremely heterosexual.
And the first
paragraph-- I'm going
to read the first
paragraph out loud,
because it's one of my
favorite first paragraphs.
"The first time I laid
eyes on Terry Lennox,
he was drunk in a Rolls
Royce Silver Wraith
outside the terrace
of the dancers.
The parking lot attendant
had brought the car out,
and he was still
holding the door open,
because Terry Lennox's
left foot was still
dangling outside as if he
had forgotten he had one.
He had a young looking face,
but his hair was bone white.
You could tell by
his eyes that he
was plastered to the
hairline, but otherwise, he
looked like any other nice
guy in a dinner jacket who
had been spending too
much money in a joint that
exists for that purpose
and for no other."
I like the way it kind
of delves you into-- it
seems glamorous for a minute.
Oh, he's in this car,
and he looks this way,
and what a glamorous life.
And then there's this
kind of seething cynical
that exists for that
purpose and no other.
That is, for Raymond
Chandler and Philip Marlowe,
his detective, in particular
are full of this kind
of constant cynical judgment
on these people who he's
doing anything in the world
to help, which is fun.
DAN STONE: Yeah.
Yeah.
Incredible tone to it.
And I love how-- you do this
in your writing a lot, too,
and this is something
that usually-- I
remember we published a
short story of Daniel's
in this first issue.
Usually, you point
out when somebody
repeats a word too
close together,
because it's something
you're just not supposed
to do in writing.
And this whole paragraph
is tied together
with just repeated words,
one sentence after the other.
But he pulls it off.
It kind of creates
this nice cadence.
I love that.
DANIEL HANDLER:
The fact that you
can't repeat words
is something you get
taught when you're writing
essays in high school,
and then some people
never have figured out
that they should follow
their own moral path
and not listen to
the person telling
them to lay off the case.
DAN STONE: Yeah.
Yeah.
Exactly.
And then Lemony Snicket sort
came out of this tradition--
or, the new series.
DANIEL HANDLER: Yeah.
So, illustrated by
graphic novelist Seth.
I don't know if there are comics
fans in the audience today.
I don't know why I
would think there would
be comics fans in the
audience here at Google,
but maybe some of
you know people
who are into geek culture.
I got Seth to illustrate
it by going to WonderCon
in San Francisco, which
is-- I'd never been
to a comics convention before.
DANIEL HANDLER: Never?
DANIEL HANDLER: I was told
that WonderCon is the smaller,
artier one, which,
kind of, maybe.
But I don't know what I
thought in my head, but I saw,
oh, Seth is going to be signing.
I'm interested in
working with him.
I'm going to go to WonderCon.
It's the smaller, artier one.
So I think in my
head, it was like,
I don't know what-- four people
in a room with a bottle of gin.
And I'll go up to Seth,
and it'll work out nicely.
And I walked in, and
literally when I walked in,
an army of
Stormtroopers ran by me.
And I had to recalibrate smaller
and artier for [INAUDIBLE].
And then I was talking to
one of the Stormtroopers,
who was saying, oh,
yeah, we're reenacting
this battle in this other room.
We have all these people going.
And he said, you know,
like Civil War reenactors.
And then he kept moving up.
And I felt like, oh, yeah,
except the Civil War happened.
It's kind of a big difference.
So they're not reenacting.
They're just acting.
To which I have no
objection, but I just
thought it was a
distinction worth making.
Like, people really
died in the Civil War.
It really tore
our country apart.
Tattooine is fine, what
with never existing.
Maybe that's hard for people
to hear, but you have a drink.
You have a drink.
Slam it down if
you can't take it.
And so I went to him, and
he was a lonely island,
if you'll pardon the expression,
in the middle of WonderCon.
He was literally in the shadow
of a huge statue of the Human
Torch.
He was sitting in a
suit, signing copies
of his very, very sad and
miserable graphic novels.
I mean, they're beautifully
made, but they're miserable.
They're all about
depressed people.
And I think if he hadn't
met me in that context,
he wouldn't have agreed to
do it, but he did, so he did.
DAN STONE: There we go.
DANIEL HANDLER: I think he
was so desperate and lonely
and surrounded by the noise
of corporate superheroes
that he was like, somebody
wants to do something?
Sure.
I'll do that.
DAN STONE: He didn't
know you were coming?
DANIEL HANDLER: No.
DAN STONE: And you were
there just to find him?
DANIEL HANDLER: Yeah.
Well, my wife is an
illustrator, and she
was on a panel,
which was a disaster.
And so I said, oh, well,
I'm coming with her
for moral support.
And then, oh,
look, Seth is here.
DAN STONE: Great.
DANIEL HANDLER:
She was on a panel,
and it was right when the
Walking Dead came out,
and there was the creator
of The Walking Dead,
and then four illustrators
no one cared about.
So my wife had to just sit
there while 3,600 people were
like, I have a question
about episode three.
But the world of "All
The Wrong Questions"
is the world of
noir, and that tone
that I read you in
Raymond Chandler.
I'll now read a
paragraph from this book,
and you can see how
I ripped it off.
Lemony Snicket is
narrating this.
In this, he's an apprentice in
the secret organization that
is in "A Series of
Unfortunate Events."
He's about 13, and he's in this
lonely industrial town called
Stained by the Sea that has
made the mistake of draining
the sea.
So it's no longer by
the sea, so it's even
more desolate and lonely
than it was before.
"I used to be that
young man, almost 13,
walking alone down an empty
street in a half faded town.
I used to be that person
eating stale peanuts
and wondering about
a strange dusty item
that was stolen or
forgotten and that
belonged to one
family or another,
or their enemies,
or their friends.
Before that, I was a child
receiving an unusual education,
and before that,
I was a baby who
I'm told liked
looking in mirrors
and sticking his
toes into his mouth.
I used to be that young man
and that child and that baby,
and the building I
stood in front of
used to be a City Hall.
Stretched out in front
of me was my time
as an adult, and
then a skeleton,
and then nothing except perhaps
a few books on a few shelves."
Yeah.
He's thinking about
death a lot in this book.
DAN STONE: Fantastic.
DANIEL HANDLER:
I think you start
thinking about
death at 13, maybe.
DAN STONE: Yeah.
DANIEL HANDLER: Is
that when you started?
DAN STONE: 12 or 13.
Maybe even 11.
13, I think, is a good age.
I taught middle
school for a while.
DANIEL HANDLER: Me too.
DAN STONE: You
taught middle school?
DANIEL HANDLER: I taught
eighth grade, yeah.
DAN STONE: Oh.
I don't know how we've never
known that about each other.
DANIEL HANDLER: We both
like eighth graders.
DAN STONE: That's true.
DANIEL HANDLER:
That came out wrong.
DAN STONE: Yeah, that did.
That did.
But yeah.
I think that's when
that dark side starts
to register a little
bit with kids.
DANIEL HANDLER: Macbeth.
I taught Macbeth to eighth
graders, and they loved it.
They open on witches.
Come on.
That's like, the smartest--
DAN STONE: One of
my students is here.
Anne Farmer, who organized
the event-- her son Nick
was my student.
And I taught the films
of Ingmar Bergman.
A week long class
where all we did
was watch Bergman eight hours
a day, and they loved it.
DANIEL HANDLER: Yeah.
DAN STONE: They
absolutely loved it.
Not even "The Magic Lantern."
They liked the really
strange dark stuff.
DANIEL HANDLER: My middle
school was about two blocks
from the Parkside Theatre,
which is no longer there,
but it was on [INAUDIBLE]
in San Francisco.
It was an art house
theater of the old school.
And they had marathon days.
And I can't believe I had
the stamina to do this,
but we would go-- I went to
Bergman day, and Kurosawa day,
and Woody Allen day,
and Orson Welles day.
And they would show
like 12 movies in a row.
And she would maybe take lunch
during one of the boring movies
and come back.
It was crazy.
Now I can't believe I did that.
DAN STONE: Yeah.
DANIEL HANDLER: And
on Friday nights,
they'd stop making sense, and
they'd pull all the risers out
so you could dance.
DAN STONE: Wow.
That sounds fun.
DANIEL HANDLER: It was another
thing to do with girls.
Besides roll around
in a forest, I mean.
DAN STONE: I want to
start another drink.
DANIEL HANDLER: Yeah.
I better finish the first one.
DAN STONE: Yeah.
Finish up the first one.
DANIEL HANDLER: This is where
you get in trouble, I always
think, in drinking, is
when someone's like, hey,
you ready for another one?
And you're not.
And you're like,
yeah, yeah, sure!
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
DAN STONE: We have an hour.
We've got three drinks here,
so we've got to keep it moving.
DANIEL HANDLER: That's right.
We have drinking to do.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
DAN STONE: That only happens
at a bar at closing time.
All right.
So here, we've got an old
fashioned to go with the poem
that we're going to talk about.
And we'll show you
the poem in a second.
But house bacon infused
Four Roses bourbon.
So I went to Berkeley
Bowl yesterday,
and they dragged a pig out from
the back of the butcher shop,
and carved three pounds of fat.
DANIEL HANDLER: Already dead.
The pig was already dead.
DAN STONE: Yeah,
the pig was dead.
DANIEL HANDLER: I
had this fantasy
about how the customers
of Berkeley Bowl
would take to a pig being
slaughtered in the store,
you know?
Because they're self
righteous about,
like, are these
heirloom tomatoes?
It says organic, but is
it the kind of organic--
And then just if you were
like, hold on one second.
We're killing a pig.
We'll get to you in a minute.
DAN STONE: So yeah.
It was already dead.
So they carved three pounds
of fat off the side of it,
and then we rendered that.
DANIEL HANDLER: What
does that mean, render?
DAN STONE: Cook it
down until it's liquid.
DANIEL HANDLER: Oh yeah?
DAN STONE: Yeah.
DANIEL HANDLER: So you
just put it in a pot?
DAN STONE: Yeah.
I put it in a covered pot.
DANIEL HANDLER:
That pot is going
to make everything taste
delicious for the next nine
years.
DAN STONE: I know.
Well, it actually went
into several vessels.
Like, my coffee
pot-- I could still
taste a little bit of
bacon in it this morning.
So you steep it for four hours.
DANIEL HANDLER: We're with the
American Medical Association,
by the way.
Put a little bacon fat in
your coffee every morning.
DAN STONE: You steep
it for four hours,
then freeze it for two hours.
The one ingredient
we have that's
not up there is coffee beans.
So it's also got a little
bit of caffeine in it.
DANIEL HANDLER: Yeah.
So it's like having a coke.
Just going to put you
right on an even keel.
DAN STONE: I don't know if a
vegetarian wants to drink it.
It's up to you.
There's not actually
bacon fat in it still,
but the flavor of it's there.
So maybe that's what
a vegetarian could do.
Maybe this is the perfect
drink to get away with.
DANIEL HANDLER: Well,
that's a great line
to see what kind of
vegetarian they are, right?
DAN STONE: Yeah.
Exactly.
I was at a wedding
recently with a vegan.
DANIEL HANDLER: Cheers.
DAN STONE: Cheers.
DANIEL HANDLER: That's good.
DAN STONE: It's not bad, right?
DANIEL HANDLER: Yeah.
It tastes a little breakfast-y.
DAN STONE: Yeah.
Well, a little maple
syrup, and yeah.
Get coffee in the aftertaste.
DANIEL HANDLER: You do have
coffee in the aftertaste.
DAN STONE: Yeah.
So yeah.
Old fashioneds
are coming around.
So we made this drink
to pair with a poem
that we want to talk.
We'll read it to you.
DANIEL HANDLER: There it is.
DAN STONE: It's coming up.
All right.
Want to read it?
DANIEL HANDLER: Yeah.
"Everything Will Be
Fixed By Love."
"Everyone woke up hungover.
Everyone woke up
in the wrong bed.
Everyone had the wrong
shoe on the wrong foot
in the wrong weather.
Everyone was so hungry.
Then everyone ate too much.
Love me everyone said.
Love me first everyone said.
Fix me everyone said.
Fix me first."
I like this poem a lot.
Part of it is that I'm addicted
lately to the word wrong,
which was in "All the Wrong
Questions," because it's
instantly narrative.
That's just a word that I
started falling in love with.
"He opened the
wrong door," right?
That's already a story.
DAN STONE: I like that.
DANIEL HANDLER: Right?
DAN STONE: That's great.
DANIEL HANDLER: She was
waiting at the bus stop,
and out stepped the wrong girl.
DAN STONE: Yeah.
DANIEL HANDLER: It's great.
DAN STONE: And three
times in this poem.
DANIEL HANDLER: And I was
talking to another poet,
and she likes it with real.
She says, I like it with real,
because when you put real
in front of anything,
it automatically
sounds like it's not real.
Like, have some real lemonade?
And you're like,
what's going on?
[LAUGHTER]
DANIEL HANDLER: I'm gonna
wake up without a kidney.
So an old fashioned is another
really classic cocktail.
Usually, if you order
it at your average bar,
it has fruit salad at
the bottom, basically.
It has a slice of orange
and a maraschino cherry.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
DANIEL HANDLER:
Like the old fruit
salad of your grandmother,
and then bourbon on top.
To which I have no
objection, by the way.
DAN STONE: It's fine, yeah.
So that is the
new old fashioned.
The old old fashioned,
which I didn't actually
make it live up here-- we
already had it premade,
because I accidentally
batched all of it,
and then realized I didn't
have any of the bourbon
left to make it
for you in person.
DANIEL HANDLER: Oh yeah?
DAN STONE: But anyway.
DANIEL HANDLER: Still good.
DAN STONE: Yeah.
So the old old
fashioned is just simply
bourbon, bitters, and sugar.
And then at some
point, they started
making a new old
fashioned, where
they would muddle the fruit
salad-- maraschino cherries
and orange slices.
But this is a little
more extravagant
than with maple syrup
and bacon and coffee.
But this is more the old
school old fashioned.
DANIEL HANDLER: Yeah.
And supposedly, it's
the oldest cocktail.
DAN STONE: Right.
Well, they also say
that about the sazerac.
DANIEL HANDLER: Plus I
just figure, you know, now
some caveman was drinking some
distillation of something,
and then he was like, oh,
a little grass got in it.
And he was like, well,
I'm not throwing it out.
I'm a caveman.
DAN STONE: Right
DANIEL HANDLER: I
mean, he probably
wasn't that self aware
about being a caveman.
But still, the
point was, you know,
he was like,
distillation's hard.
I'm not throwing this out
because I got something in it.
And that was probably
the first cocktail.
DAN STONE: It
probably was, yeah.
DANIEL HANDLER: They're
like, Ugg, it's delicious.
DAN STONE: What did
you put in this?
DANIEL HANDLER: What is it?
Tastes grassy.
Tastes a little grassy.
Tastes like mastodon blood.
What is it?
DAN STONE: So we were
drinking old fashions
while we were talking about
what we were going to do here,
and you pulled this
poem out of your wallet.
You carry poems in your wallet.
DANIEL HANDLER: I keep
poems in my wallet.
DAN STONE: Show them one
of them, because they've
been in there for a
while, and you can tell.
This was one of them.
He pulled this out and said,
we can talk about this.
DANIEL HANDLER: You're
never sorry if you
have a poem in your wallet.
Even though this is
something I never
did-- I never kept a
condom in my wallet--
but I feel like
it feels that way.
Like, you never know!
Bring a poem.
You don't know
what's gonna happen.
You don't know.
Because you might
need both, and you
could stop at a
drugstore for a condom,
but where are you
going to get a poem?
Yeah.
I'm not going to read
them all, thank goodness.
But here it is.
I'm also working on a
new book about people
who are troubled in
love, and I liked this.
And it has a panicky
feel to it, which I feel,
when you're young and in love,
or looking to be in love,
or love is over, there's
a pulsey, panicky thing
that happens.
DAN STONE: Yeah, yeah.
The whole poem's about
getting too much of something
and trying to deal
with the consequences.
Everyone wakes up hungover.
DANIEL HANDLER: Yeah.
And sympathy for
somebody else, but still
not putting them first.
DAN STONE: Right.
DANIEL HANDLER: Love me
first, everyone said.
Fix me first.
You have sympathy for, like, oh,
the whole world's in trouble,
but still, my troubles
should actually be first.
Which feels like a young
and in love problem.
And it reminds me of the first
time I had an old fashioned,
I was in my early 20s, and
I was at the first meeting
with my literary agent, who
is still my literary agent.
But I had my first
novel, "The Basic Eight."
I'd given her 50 pages.
She said she liked
it, and then she said,
I'm going to happen to
be in San Francisco.
Come have a drink with me.
Which was-- I was so
young, and working at a job
that I had no commitment to
and wasn't a good employee at.
So it seemed really glamorous
to go downtown to San Francisco
and have a drink with
a literary agent.
And I didn't know what
I was going to do.
I didn't know, like,
do I bring a gift?
How does this work?
So I only had one suit
and one nice white shirt
then that I had to pin
together with safety pins,
because the buttons were gone.
So I wore those.
Classy.
And then she sat
down, and she said,
I'll have an old fashioned.
And I was like, yeah,
me too, of course.
And then thinking, I
wonder what that is.
And then hoping
that there wasn't a
follow up question,
because I didn't
know anything about
cocktails then.
DAN STONE: How do you like it?
DANIEL HANDLER: Yeah.
Like, oh, yeah?
How do you like it?
I'd be like, oh, with
a wing wang wunnamunga.
You know.
Belgian style.
Yeah.
But [INAUDIBLE].
They just brought me it.
And it's a good drink to
nurse, because the ice melts,
and everything
continues to be nice.
And so if you're worried
about getting drunk
during your first meeting
with a literary agent,
you can just kind of nurture it.
DAN STONE: It's always
a good drink to order.
No one ever has a problem with
ordering an old fashioned,
even if you get the
fruit salad kind.
I went around the city with
a few friends the other day
on bicycles, and we
got an old fashioned
from every bar we walked into.
Maybe six places.
DANIEL HANDLER: I
hope you had a helmet.
DAN STONE: We did, yeah.
We had a helmet.
We wore it in the bar.
DANIEL HANDLER: Yeah.
Can't be too careful.
DAN STONE: Yeah.
Exactly.
And they weren't all great,
but it's an old fashioned.
So even if they're
not great, it's
one of those drinks
that's still pretty good.
Not all drinks are like that.
DANIEL HANDLER: And I would
say that's my connection to it
with poetry.
A, it's old, and it's being
reinvented all the time.
And that I'm a big
reader of poetry,
and a big believer
in poetry, and I
try to be something of a
proselytizer about poetry,
because I feel like if you
read poetry on a regular basis,
you will achieve a calm state
that no other work of art, I
think, can provide.
And particularly now
in the world online,
it's really easy to find
poetry really easily.
Actually, through
Poetry Foundation
and through Poetry
Magazine, they'll
send you one in your
inbox every day.
And like an old fashioned,
it's not always great,
but it's never quite terrible.
The poems that come from
the Poetry Foundation.
I don't mean no
poetry is terrible.
DAN STONE: OK, yeah.
Yeah, I agree.
DANIEL HANDLER: And I like
thinking about poetry,
because it's really old.
I write novels, and the
novel was invented--
DAN STONE: It's a new form.
DANIEL HANDLER: There are
different theories about when
the first novel was, but
they're all not so long ago.
And poetry traces back to
when people were talking.
And it's fascinating to me.
And the practitioners of poetry,
particularly if you put a drink
in them, will begin talking
about the ancient tradition
in a way that you
find fascinating.
Although they're poets, so you
have to pay for the drinks.
DAN STONE: That's true.
That's true.
Why do you think it
creates that sense of calm?
DANIEL HANDLER: This will
sound kind of woo-woo,
but I'm on the second drink.
I think that it
puts you in touch
with this very
ancient tradition.
I think in reading
a poem, you're
attaching yourself so
this long, glorious thing.
And I think part of being in
the world is attaching yourself
to something larger.
And I'm not a religious
person, for instance,
but that's an obvious
way in which people
attach themself to
something larger.
But I think even
that's why people
like to work at big
companies sometimes.
You like to be part of
something that's happening.
And poetry was invented
to make people feel better
about the world.
DAN STONE: And to
remember things.
DANIEL HANDLER: When
people would say,
this is an old, ancient thing
that we say every morning,
and it makes us feel
better, and makes
us feel like we're not going to
get eaten by a mastodon today.
And it's appealing.
DAN STONE: I think that
too, especially coming down
to talk here today.
The oldest poetry we have was a
way of remembering our stories,
because we set it down in
language that you can't forget.
That will have these devices
like rhyme and meter, which
they all did back then.
So you could memorize.
That was a category in the
ancient Olympics-- poetry
recitation.
People would remember
thousands of lines of poetry,
and you'd preserve the
stories of your culture.
Now we sort of do that
largely through Google
and things like that.
The internet.
The stories are
preserved that way.
DANIEL HANDLER: But even
things that I think of as poems
are kind of slogans,
like no shirt, no shoes,
no service is a poem
that makes you remember
certain things that are the
basics of polite society.
Which is that you should
wear a shirt and shoes,
and then people will serve you.
That's a good thing to remember.
DAN STONE: Yeah.
I mean, I also am a
big lover of poetry.
I think probably not
a lot of people are.
Obviously not a lot
of people are anymore.
DANIEL HANDLER: I don't know.
It's one of those things where
if you show it to somebody,
everybody likes it.
But people forget
to seek it out,
so I like to be a
walking billboard for it.
While I'm being a walking
billboard for Google.
DAN STONE: Right.
Yeah.
I think people also turn
to it in difficult times,
more than they'll
turn to anything else.
Maybe music, but when
something goes wrong--
like, always at a
funeral, there's poetry.
Or after September
11th, poetry everywhere.
That's sort of how people
make sense of things.
Anyway.
DANIEL HANDLER: Anyway,
I'm in favor of it.
DAN STONE: Yeah.
Pro-poetry.
DANIEL HANDLER: You publish
poets in Radio Silence.
DAN STONE: Yeah, we do.
And we have a great conversation
between Robert Pinsky,
the British poet, and
Bruce Springsteen.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
DANIEL HANDLER: And it
turns out Bruce Springsteen
is a big Robert Pinsky fan.
That's the most
fascinating part of it.
So it starts with
Bruce Springsteen
saying, like, hey,
I love your work.
DAN STONE: Yeah.
Big fan.
DANIEL HANDLER: Which is not how
you thought it was going to go.
DAN STONE: Right, right.
Yeah.
So usually in each
issue of Radio Silence,
we'll publish a contemporary
poet and something old.
Something in public
domain that's
sort of been overlooked
or forgotten.
But yeah, in the
issue you have, it
begins with this
conversation between the two
that happened at
Farley Dickinson
University in New Jersey.
And no one's ever seen it.
They won't release it.
I got a bootleg of
it, and Bruce's people
liked the magazine,
and said they'd
let us publish an excerpt of it.
But what happened in it-- and
I'll show it to you sometime.
We'll drink old
fashioneds and watch it.
Springsteen started-- Pinsky's
got that great poem, "Samurai
Song," which is
a beautiful poem.
And Springsteen was
talking about how much
he liked his work.
And at one point,
he just started
to recite "Samurai Song."
He had a guitar in his
lap, and he just slowly
played a few chords
along with it
as he was reciting
it from memory.
And he just eased into the
"Darkness on the Edge of Town."
And it was just this
mind-blowingly amazing
performance, but they won't
let us do anything with it.
So the people in
the room saw it.
DANIEL HANDLER:
Someday, the lawyers
will arm wrestle it out.
DAN STONE: Yeah.
They should.
It's really great.
DANIEL HANDLER: Another
thing I like about poetry
and poets is that
rock stars love poets.
And it's really fun sometimes
to watch a rock star get blown
away, because they're
not used to that,
or you're not used to seeing it.
DAN STONE: Right.
Well, I mean, song lyrics-- it's
probably more popular any type
of literature we have right now.
They're just poems set to music.
DANIEL HANDLER: Yeah.
DAN STONE: So I guess
it persists that way.
DANIEL HANDLER: "Caught
Your Eye But Not Your Name."
That's a pop song
I'm into right now,
and I thought it was a
great line of poetry.
I caught your eye,
but not your name?
It's great.
DAN STONE: Yeah.
Yeah.
It is good.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
DANIEL HANDLER: You know
what's another great song?
"Pretty Boy."
I heard they have happy hour
at Google Wednesday, Thursday
and Friday.
So we're getting you through.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
DANIEL HANDLER: Between
the weekend and when happy
hour starts.
DAN STONE: I think we're going
to go onto another drink.
DANIEL HANDLER: Yeah.
Yeah.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
DANIEL HANDLER:
Because we talked
about a book that I love, and
a poem that I love, and then
we're going to show
a scene from a movie
I love, which we saved
for last, because that's
the easiest thing to experience.
DAN STONE: Yeah.
DANIEL HANDLER: And
we'll all be plastered.
And the movie is a
Mexican melodrama.
Here it is on DVD.
We both brought this.
I don't really know why.
So we can hold it up.
See?
And you thought I was lying.
DAN STONE: You carry it with
you everywhere, don't you?
DANIEL HANDLER: I kind of do.
DAN STONE: He loves this movie.
And I do, too.
It's great.
But I didn't know it until
you told me about it.
DANIEL HANDLER: No one does.
And it's nice about having
a favorite movie that no one
else has seen is you
get to show to them.
And I saw this movie
for the first time
in the mid-'90s at
the Castro Theater,
and I moved to New York, and
it started playing in New York
right after I moved there.
And so I saw it again
with a friend of mine.
I saw two showings in a row.
I saw it with one
friend, and then
I said goodbye to
my friend, and then
I just waited
outside the theater,
and my other friend came,
and we went and saw it again.
And I didn't admit
it, because it
was going to be too
crazy to say that I
wanted to show
people this movie.
And it's great.
"La Aventurera," or
"The Adventurist."
It's a 1950s kind
of noir melodrama.
It's Mexican.
I'm going to say the first
five minutes of the movie,
because it's so insane.
Our hero, Elena,
skips down the stairs.
And we should say
that our heroine
is played by this
talentless actress.
She can't act, and she can't
sing, and she can't dance,
and she does all of
them in the movie.
And so the movie
is also this kind
of love story from the
director, who, big surprise,
was in love with this woman.
So he's made this movie
around this woman.
And he just says, well,
I'm taking it as a given
that everyone finds
this woman irresistible.
And find her utterly
irresistible.
So I love that it's this
movie where he's like, right?
Am I right?
The best dancer in the world.
And you're like, mm, no.
But she is taking dance
classes and living
with her kind of
uptight parents--
her sensitive father
and her brusque mother.
And a man-- a family
friend-- comes up
to take her to dance class.
And the mom says,
no, I don't want you
with that family friend.
He flirts with you too much.
You go by yourself.
So she goes by herself to dance
class, and when she gets back,
she finds her mother in the
arms of the family friend.
[GASP] And then the father
gets home and learns this,
and goes into the study
and shoots himself.
And then Elena leaves the
house, and you get a flashback.
You've gotten so many things--
DAN STONE: This
is in 10 minutes.
DANIEL HANDLER: That's
one of my favorite things.
In the first eight
minutes of the film,
there's a flashback to
what you've just seen,
because there's so much
shocking information.
She's in the street
being like, oh no!
And then it shows the
scene of it going on.
And she's like, I
can't handle it!
And I love that it mimics
your reaction as the viewer.
Because you're like, I
can't handle any of it.
This is insane.
Anyway, she ends up in
a white slavery thing.
That's complicated.
She ends up kind of in
a white slavery ring
run by the mother of
her subsequent lover.
It's complicated.
But what we're going to show
is one of the dance scenes,
which, for me, because
it's the third drink,
I think we all want to stare
rapturously at this movie that
is a love story about an
irresistible woman who's
utterly resistible for
everyone else but the director
of the film.
DAN STONE: You
know, it's funny you
say that, because everything
I've read about this film,
everyone just complements her.
I found her to be not--
DANIEL HANDLER: She's the
Elizabeth Berkley of her day,
I think.
It reminds me of Elizabeth
Berkeley in "Showgirls."
Distinctly.
DAN STONE: Touche.
DANIEL HANDLER: Yeah.
I mean, I found her to
not be a terrible actress
to carry this movie, just
because the movie is so
over the top.
Just so melodramatic.
Just unapologetically excessive.
DAN STONE: Yeah.
DANIEL HANDLER: And
there's poetry in it.
I find it very
beautiful, this movie.
I mean, it's
ridiculous, but when
you get past it
being ridiculous,
and you get all the way
all around the circle,
it starts to makes sense to.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
DAN STONE: You done with that?
You ready for another?
So this one's a little
bold for non-drinkers.
So this is the Rosa Juarez--
DANIEL HANDLER: You can see
who has a meeting later.
Some people are like, huh.
It's fine.
We won't pressure you.
I mean, we will, because we are.
DAN STONE: A lot of the
movie takes place in Juarez.
A lot of the darker
scenes take place there.
After she leaves the happy
home life, she goes there.
Which, at the time, in
Mexico, I was reading about,
there was a sort of
urbanization period
around then where those cities
became just dens of sin.
Juarez in particular.
So it's sort of about that.
There's a whole category
films that this came out
of a tradition, and this is
sort of the best of them.
But we've got Mezcal,
which is smoky.
DANIEL HANDLER: It's like
tequila's disreputable brother.
DAN STONE: Yeah.
But a good Mezcal is as
good as a good tequila.
I mean, it can be incredible.
DANIEL HANDLER: But I
feel like tequila's like,
hey, let's party.
Don't talk to my brother.
And the brother's like,
I'm doing something.
Don't come in here.
I'll be at the
party in a minute.
Is that someone screaming?
No, she's fine.
She's fine.
Don't come in here.
DAN STONE: So Mezcal is a
smoky version of tequila.
You the smoke go
through the distillate.
So it's the same
difference between scotch
and other kinds of whiskey.
Smoke goes through
the distillate,
makes it a smoky drink.
So you have Mazcal,
Campari-- which you
I'm sure you've all seen.
This goes in Negronis
Italian liquor.
DANIEL HANDLER: There are
two things about Campari.
One is that they
always say it's made
from the hulls of dead insects,
which I don't think is true,
and it's because
of the word dead.
It's like the word
wrong, or the word real.
People have said
to me, oh, you know
that's made from the
hulls of dead insects.
And I think, like, why say dead?
They're definitely dead.
So therefore, the
whole story is suspect.
And the other is that
it rhymes in Italian,
and I can't recite it.
But Campari had an Italian--
well, it's an Italian liqueur,
but it had an
Italian ad campaign
that said, "Like love, the
first six times you try it,
it won't work out."
Isn't that amazing?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
DANIEL HANDLER: And then also,
I think it's just amazing.
We're in America.
We don't have companies
that say you're not
gonna like it at first, right?
DAN STONE: Yeah.
Wow.
I've never heard that.
DANIEL HANDLER: It
says, like, hey, we've
made changes to Google Maps.
Come see.
It doesn't say, OK, you're
going to be really confused.
It's going to be super hard, but
you're going to get used to it.
You'll get with it, but
you gotta stay with it.
Your first reaction is
going to be negative.
That's not what
we say in America.
And in Italy, they're
like, you'll come back.
You'll be fine.
DAN STONE: Just keep with it.
DANIEL HANDLER: Yeah.
Stay with it.
It's like love.
It won't work out at first.
And you put salt?
DAN STONE: So, Dolin
dry vermouth, yeah.
And then a pinch
of salt, which has
this nice effect with
any Campari drink.
Also great in Negronis.
It sort of takes the
edge off the bitterness,
and it's strange.
It actually brings the
sweetness of the drink out.
So a little pinch of salt.
You stir up in it, and yeah,
finish it with a lemon peel.
So you've got lemon
zest on yours,
even though you don't
have a peel in it.
DANIEL HANDLER: Whoo!
DAN STONE: Yeah, cheers.
DANIEL HANDLER: Cheers.
It smells really strong.
Yeah.
That's that brother, right?
You can see his belt
buckle while you drink.
DAN STONE: You can
taste the salt, though.
DANIEL HANDLER: You're
like, it's a skull,
but the skin isn't
all off the skull.
What kind of belt buckle's that?
I told you not to come in here.
Don't come in here.
DAN STONE: Yeah.
There you have it.
DANIEL HANDLER: All right.
Let's put on the movie.
DAN STONE: Yeah.
Let's do that.
So she has to perform
at a nightclub as part
of the white slavery ring.
[BEGIN VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[GONG RINGING]
DANIEL HANDLER: It's an enormous
deep set for a nightclub, eh?
I won't do too much
running commentary,
but I'll say that I love how the
offensive Arabian stereotypes
seem less offensive because
it's a Mexican movie.
Which is not true.
It shouldn't be less offensive.
But it is.
There she is.
Right?
Can't dance.
Yeah.
But everybody else can dance.
And they must be
seethingly jealous.
So you can imagine with
the different angles,
you're having dinner about
half a mile from this.
This is what's going on.
No one can see it, because
the stage is so deep.
That's a pretty
good gig, I think.
Male extra in the dance show.
That is a good gig.
DAN STONE: We could keep
it going and talk over it.
DANIEL HANDLER:
Yeah, I think so.
DAN STONE: Because we don't
have a whole lot of time left.
DANIEL HANDLER: And yet, we
won't be able to talk over it,
because it's so hypnotizing.
DAN STONE: Yeah.
It's too good.
I think the strange thing,
too, is that most of the film
is not like this.
There's maybe three
or four dance numbers,
and the rest of it's
kind of like a noir.
DANIEL HANDLER: Yeah.
Most of it is about
this white slavery ring.
But it was difficult to choose
a scene, and I just thought,
this is a great scene.
I think there's something so
gossamer about this movie,
because you see that the
director loves, loves,
loves this actress.
It's kind of like
"Annie Hall," right?
And this is great.
Like, no one's above her.
She's on the floor
in a dance thing,
so the above view
is really wasted
on everyone but the director.
This is terrible.
Look at this.
Awful.
She's like, don't
buy me earrings,
because I was just taking
down my Christmas tree,
so I'm all set.
DAN STONE: Yeah,
I love that move.
The movie has a lot of
guys in an alley with a gun
slowly coming up on somebody,
and then somebody else
throws a knife at them.
There's a lot of dark
scenes like that.
DANIEL HANDLER:
This is interesting,
because I know someone else
who edits a literary magazine,
and I asked him,
what do you look for?
And he says, the
element of surprise.
If I'm reading a
short story, I want
as many surprises as possible.
If I'm reading a piece, I want
And I thought about that about
looking at all kinds of stuff.
And this is a movie where
about eight times while you're
watching the movie, you
think, as God as my witness,
I have no idea what's
going to happen next.
Which-- you can't
say that-- oh my God.
Yeah.
If you're somebody who
dances in the mirror at home,
this is a great movie to make
you feel good about yourself.
DAN STONE: So what
do you love about it?
Is it your favorite movie?
DANIEL HANDLER: I mean, I have
other movies that I love a lot.
There's the nefarious boyfriend.
You should stop it.
Otherwise, I'm just going
to be hypnotized by it.
I like a ridiculous plot.
I mean, that's what "A Series
of Unfortunate Events" is.
I like things that
keep happening.
I like a lot of surprises
in a story, myself.
And my parents were
big opera fans,
and so we would go out to
free operas in the park
when I was growing
up, and my mother
would act out the plot of the
opera with Fisher Price toys
before we went so I would
know what was happening.
And so I say this to
my mother all the time.
I call it and say to
her-- because she acts out
the end of Carmen
where she says,
you said you'd be my girlfriend!
Pow!
Which is basically
the end of Carmen.
DAN STONE: Yeah.
DANIEL HANDLER: And
so I like a story
in which a lot is happening.
And I like the point at
which melodrama becomes
moving, which I think happens
with this movie is that there's
some real loyalty, and
there's some real--
and I think that that's amazing,
when something ridiculous can
become something moving.
And that's something that I try
to do with the Lemony Snicket
books.
That's something I try
to do with all my work,
really, is have something
where something is really
happening all the
time, but still
try to find that
moving through line.
Because to me, that's life.
Life is ridiculous.
Which doesn't mean that
it isn't incredibly
moving and beautiful.
DAN STONE: Convincing.
DANIEL HANDLER:
This is powerful.
DAN STONE: Yeah.
Yeah, this is.
DANIEL HANDLER: The
disreputable brother.
I can't stop thinking about
the disreputable brother.
DAN STONE: I know, I know.
But there's something
feminine to it,
with the Campari
in there, you know?
DANIEL HANDLER: Yeah?
I guess so.
DAN STONE: I mean, at
least to the look of it.
But it reminded
me this character.
DANIEL HANDLER: That's for sure.
DAN STONE: The character
who was up there.
Yeah.
DANIEL HANDLER: What's her name?
Nina?
DAN STONE: Yeah.
She was a Cuban actress.
Ninon Sevilla.
DANIEL HANDLER: And the
whole movie's on YouTube,
so you can watch it.
DAN STONE: Oh, I didn't know.
DANIEL HANDLER: Yeah.
DAN STONE: Oh good.
Yeah, you can watch it.
DANIEL HANDLER:
Because they were
trying to figure out if
there was permission.
We still don't know if they can
show this part on the Google
Play movie of the event,
or however it works.
The person who's
putting it together is--
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
DANIEL HANDLER:
Could he just say
what it is instead of
drunkenly saying the word
Google three times in a row?
But there's a whole
permissions thing,
and the point was made that
the whole movie's on YouTube.
How can we not show
a little bit of it?
DAN STONE: Right, yeah.
And that's fair use, right?
Gotta be.
DANIEL HANDLER: I
think all the time.
I think everything is fair use.
DAN STONE: Yeah.
They probably don't want
us to talk about it,
but yeah. you can
watch it anyway.
DANIEL HANDLER: Right.
DAN STONE: I think we
have a little bit of time
for questions.
DANIEL HANDLER: Sure.
DAN STONE: You can ask about the
film, ask about Daniel's books,
whatever you want.
DANIEL HANDLER: I wonder
what the question would be.
I'm so fascinated.
AUDIENCE: I wanted to pick up
on your point about surprise,
because I feel like there's
this tension in fiction
between a surprise that's sort
of like a cheaper plot point,
and something that is
surprising to the reader,
but actually ultimately makes
sense with the character.
So it's not like
jumping the shark,
but it's actually something that
sort of advances the character
arc.
So I was wondering if you
could speak to that tension.
DANIEL HANDLER: Well,
Hitchcock has a thing about it
that I always like,
where he says,
if you have a bomb
go off in the movie,
people are scared
for 30 seconds.
If there's a bomb
ticking, they're
scared for the whole movie.
Which, once you know
that about Hitchcock,
and you watch a
Hitchcock movie, you
see that it's always
ticking for him.
And I think that you
want to shape a story so
that every surprise makes sense.
And there's some great
surprises in the movie
here, which I won't give away.
But you think, what?
And then you're like, oh my God!
It makes the movie
so much better!
And that's an adventure.
And I think, yeah,
it's the difference
between a cheap surprise and
a kind [INAUDIBLE] surprise.
And so, Raymond Chandler
always said, when in doubt,
have a guy come in
the door with a gun.
DAN STONE: Right.
DANIEL HANDLER: And when
you read his lesser work,
it totally works that way.
You read for like 20 pages, and
you're like, I'm kind of bored.
And then, dun dun dun!
And it doesn't really
make any sense.
In fact, sometimes that'll
be the end of a chapter,
and the next chapter, he'll
be like, put that gun away.
And the guy's like,
oh, sorry, because it
didn't make any sense.
And in his best work,
when he was drinking less,
all the surprises get thicker
and thicker and thicker,
which is what happens
with "The Long Goodbye."
DAN STONE: Which
is not necessarily
what happens with
this film, though.
There are a few
surprises in there
that are so outlandish that
when they happen, you're like,
I kind of love that
they just did that,
because that couldn't
be more ridiculous.
And I don't think
we should say them,
because people should
watch this film, but--
DANIEL HANDLER: No.
But I mean, sometime we'll drink
and watch the movie together.
DAN STONE: Oh yeah,
let's do that.
DANIEL HANDLER: But I think
that when things are the most
outsized is when you
can look at them better.
It's kind of like
an exploded view,
like what they do with LEGOs
or with Ikea furniture, where
they have the exploded view,
which just automatically
is gorgeous.
Because you think, that isn't
really how it would explode.
It wouldn't explode
neatly for me to see.
And that's when you're
able to figure it out.
And I often think that
outsized melodramatic stories
are that way.
If you really want to think
about how your loyalty is
if you're in love, or
you've been betrayed,
or you're marrying into a family
who's doing things that are not
the things you
would do, these are
questions that are
asked by this movie.
But they're asked ridiculously.
They're not asked
like an indie movie
with Susan Sarandon
as a depressed mother.
They're in this context of
a terrible dance number.
And to me, that's interesting,
when the story gets large.
It's so ridiculous
that you actually
begin to find this emotional
center to it, for me.
DAN STONE: We have
time for one more.
Let's see.
Oh, yeah.
One more question.
One last.
DANIEL HANDLER: Oh, I thought
you meant one more drink.
I'm like, I gotta actually stop.
Yes ma'am.
Take the mic.
Ask question, drop mic.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So thank you so much
for coming today.
DANIEL HANDLER:
Thanks for coming out.
AUDIENCE: I grew up with your
"Series of Unfortunate Events"
books.
I'm sure many of
you did here today.
And I was just wondering--
when writing them,
they're obviously somewhat dark.
And I think they
actually probably
shaped my worldview, in a sense.
And so I'm curious as to--
DANIEL HANDLER: And
you ended up at Google.
Interesting.
AUDIENCE: Right.
Very interesting.
DANIEL HANDLER:
You got interested
in a shadowy conspiracy,
and here you are.
AUDIENCE: Here I am.
So I was just wondering, when
you're writing for children,
so you knew what
your audience was,
did you ever think
about what you
wanted them to take
away from the books?
Or did you have any
ulterior motive or anything
in writing them,
that you were trying
to send a certain
message to children?
Did you ever think about it?
DANIEL HANDLER:
I don't think so.
I mean, sometimes I was kind
of forced to think about it.
But I think a greatly crafted
story has a great message,
and that anything that's well
made is wonderful in the way
that going and viewing someone
who does something well
is always an education.
You know?
That if you all took
a day off from Google
and went to watch
the best guy making
stained glass in
the world, you would
learn something from that,
even though, probably,
you're not engaged in the
making of stained glass a lot
here at Google.
And I think that
in the same way,
a story that's well
crafted that makes sense
can bring a lesson home.
But I didn't think
to myself, what's
a great thing to
teach 10-year-olds?
Because there's a lot of
books for 10-year-olds
that you can read that you can
tell start with that, you know?
That's like, I just want
to teach about diversity,
but I don't have an idea.
But diversity's great!
And those books are terrible.
AUDIENCE: Right.
And yours weren't.
DANIEL HANDLER: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Subtle.
DANIEL HANDLER: Well, I don't
know if I was subtle as much as
that I was not interested--
I didn't think to myself,
what a wonderful
platform you have
to teach third
graders or something.
I thought, wouldn't it be funny
if a family was thrown down
an elevator shaft?
And then I went from there.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Well, on that
note, thank you [INAUDIBLE].
DANIEL HANDLER: Yeah.
Bye, everybody.
Thanks for coming.
DAN STONE: So everybody,
thank you for being here.
And let's thank Daniel Handler.
DANIEL HANDLER: Thanks to Dan
Stone for making the drinks.
[APPLAUSE]